The Arrowverse contains a vast wealth of heroes.
But every shining knight has a weakness. These
are the weaknesses of the Arrowverse's best
and brightest, from their debilitating
phobias to their reckless attitudes.
Beth Chapel just wants to belong. While she loves
her parents, she also resents them a little,
as they stopped paying much attention to her
once she grew old enough to take care of herself.
As a result, this young genius gloms onto
Courtney Whitmore and Yolanda Montez when she
realizes they're forming some kind of secret club.
Upon learning they're superheroes, she gets even
more excited. Once Courtney realizes that Beth
has somehow managed to activate Dr. Mid-Nite's
artificial intelligence goggles, she allows her to
join the new Justice Society. However, her clingy
nature and desperate desire to prove herself
leads her to make mistakes and act impulsively.
Rick Tyler was raised by his uncle Matt.
Unbeknownst to him, his father Rex was the
hero Hourman. Rex and his wife were murdered
by Solomon Grundy, though Rick was told they
died in a car crash. As a result, Rick grows
up angry, alienating everyone around him. When
Courtney Whitmore reveals to him that his father
had been Hourman and Beth Chapel shows him the
truth of his death, he decides to turn his anger
on the Injustice Society. This anger makes him
undisciplined and sloppy. Eventually, he decides
to act for justice instead of revenge — however,
a lifetime of feeling abandoned still
makes anger his first response to stress.
Yolanda Montez has great grades, popularity,
a likely win in the upcoming student election,
and a boyfriend. When he pressures
her to send him a nude photo,
however, he shares it with everyone, humiliating
her in front of the whole school. Worse,
her parents feel that she's disgraced
them, and stop taking her to church.
It takes a persistent Courtney Whitmore to
convince her to become Wildcat and join her new
Justice Society. Still, it takes Yolanda a long
time to work through her shame: For quite a while,
she pushes everyone away. In time, she learns
to do things for the right reasons, but part of
her will always miss the life she once had. The
fact that she can never return to it haunts her.
"When those photos got around, I
was ashamed to be Yolanda Montez."
Rene Ramirez starts his career as a vigilante
with sloppy working methods. Joining Team Arrow
is an adjustment for everyone, because he
isn't used to working as part of a team,
and definitely isn't used to following orders. He
chafes at Oliver Queen's rigid leadership style,
and constantly blows up. This makes him a major
liability. It isn't until much later that he
learns how to calm down and not take everything
so personally. His passion to do the right thing
is his greatest asset, but when that passion
boils over, he's a weak link in the field.
John "Spartan" Diggle is a man who's constantly
trying to figure out his next step. He's been a
soldier, a bodyguard, and eventually, a member of
Team Arrow. As important as he is to the cause, he
is always in Oliver's shadow. This dissatisfaction
eats at him, no matter how much he loves Oliver.
Everything changes when Oliver decides to retire
for a while, leaving his role to Diggle. Being
Green Arrow clearly means the world to
him, so when Oliver takes the role back,
Diggle is devastated. His need to be something
more than he is causes him to leave Team Arrow and
move over to ARGUS — but that role doesn't suit
him either. It isn't until the end of the series,
which implies that he is chosen to be the
new Green Lantern, that he finds his place.
Curtis Holt is an Olympic decathlete, a genius
engineer, and an academic, possessing 14 different
degrees. Initially serving as part of Team Arrow's
support crew, he's beaten up by thugs and vows
to never be put in that position again. He learns
hand-to-hand combat and becomes fairly good at it,
but never quite catches up to his teammates.
Moreover, PTSD often makes him hesitate in combat.
He later struggles with anger at Oliver Queen
for putting all new members under surveillance,
the dissolution of his marriage because of his
double life, and his distaste for ARGUS' tactics.
Eventually, Curtis quits the life, but remains
available for research and intelligence.
Thea Queen starts out much like her brother:
A privileged partier who gets mixed up with a
lot of bad people. When she learns that Oliver's
arch-enemy Malcolm Merlyn is her actual father,
her life is upended. Merlyn trains her to become
a killer using League of Assassins methods.
She turns on him in time and becomes a member
of Team Arrow, but dies later on. She is
revived by the Lazarus Pit, but it gives her an
insatiable bloodlust. Once she is cured of this,
she takes a job in Oliver Queen's mayoral office
and makes some ethically dubious moves. No matter
what Thea does, she always goes too far, and
rarely considers the consequences of her actions.
Eventually, she retires from all kinds
of vigilante activity and public life.
Roy Harper credits Oliver with giving him purpose
after a hard start in life. But poor Roy suffers
as a result of becoming a crime-fighter, being
kidnapped and injected with serum that boosts his
abilities at the cost of his mental stability.
While he eventually receives an antidote,
he is later killed and resurrected by the
bloodlust-inducing Lazarus Pit. He receives the
special lotus formula to counteract this effect,
but the lingering influence of the serum continues
to urge him towards violence. Only by leaving
the vigilante life altogether can he control it.
After gaining sonic powers, detective Dinah Drake
embarks upon a violent campaign of revenge on
the criminals she believes killed her partner.
Eventually, Oliver Queen convinces her to join
Team Arrow. She ultimately finds herself torn
between various allegiances — especially after
discovering that the murderous Vigilante is in
fact her ex-partner and ex-boyfriend. She keeps
this a secret, which is a major breach of trust.
Later, she, Mr. Terrific, and Wild Dog break away
from Team Arrow after discovering they've been put
under surveillance. She is made chief of police,
which puts her allegiance to the law-breaking
Team Arrow in jeopardy. Dinah is forced to
betray the trust of either the police force, Team
Arrow, or both. When she travels to the future
after Oliver Queen's funeral, she gives up the
adventurer's life for a long time as a result.
Laurel Lance of Earth-2 wasn't lucky enough
to have a loving father around to raise her.
She drifts through life until she gains her
sonic scream, at which point she signs up with
Zoom to help him try to conquer Earth-1. She
causes further trouble assisting the likes of
Prometheus and Ricardo Diaz — but Quentin Lance,
Earth-1 Laurel's father, never gives up on her.
Eventually, she becomes a force for good.
Her biggest flaw is her urge to ignore her
newly-developed conscience — old habits die
hard, after all. Instead of blaming others,
she works hard to take her father's
love and faith in her to heart,
even though she is constantly
tempted to backslide.
Ray Palmer is a genius, but perhaps more
importantly, he's the moral compass of the
Legends. But his kind and gentle nature can
be a liability. He's not a natural fighter,
and so he's not the guy who's going to battle
to his last breath to save the day. Indeed,
he prefers sitting down with his enemies, in the
hopes of persuading them to change their minds,
rather than fight them. This makes him a decent
person, but not always the best superhero.
His deciding to leave the group in order to
start a new life with Nora makes a lot of sense:
As much as he enjoys hanging out with
his friends, he's not a lifelong soldier.
Mick Rory becomes a criminal because he hates
authority. He also struggles with guilt over
the death of his parents, who perished in
a blaze he set as a child. When he agrees
to become a Legend, it's because he wants to
steal a bunch of stuff while time traveling.
While he betrays the team more than
once, he eventually settles back
in as a cornerstone of the group — albeit,
one with a room full of stolen riches.
After he changes a timeline and accidentally
fathers a daughter, Mick finds himself with
mixed emotions. He doesn't want the responsibility
of fatherhood, but also doesn't want his daughter
to go through life without a dad. This
proves to be the one thing he can't ignore.
While he's warming to the role of parent, he
is wary of the responsibility he now shoulders.
"C'mon, I'm trying. Alright, what is our
father-daughter weekend gonna look like?"
Ava Sharpe is recruited by Rip Hunter to work for
his Time Bureau, in order to protect the timeline
with a rigid set of rules. She's all about
rigid rules, and loves her role in running
the Bureau ... until she learns the horrible truth
about her past. She's a clone who had her memories
wiped, which were replaced with fake ones. She
is later forced to fight clones of herself,
which does a number on her identity. While she
finds a home with the Legends, and the love of
her life, Sara Lance, Ava's still sensitive about
being a clone, and thus not a "real" person.
"My, my life, my memories,
they're all manufactured.
They're, they're not real. I'm not even real."
John Constantine pretends to be above it all. In
large part, this is because he's brought grief
and pain to those around him. What's worse, his
guilt with regard to hard choices he's had to make
has led him to make even worse choices
in an effort to fix things. For example,
when he tries to alter the timeline to prevent
his boyfriend from being dragged off to Hell,
it just makes the ensuing timeline more
bizarre: Zari gets turned into a cat and
the team is turned into puppets. Trying
to assuage his guilt on his own only makes
things worse for everyone, but it also makes
him even more afraid of relying on others.
Whether it's Amaya Jiwe or her granddaughters
Mari and Kuasa filling the role, the heroine
known as Vixen is always bound to defend Zambesi
Village with the Anansi Totem. Amaya does spend
time away from her tribe as Vixen during World
War II when she joins the Justice Society,
and then joins the time-spanning Legends.
But she knows that her time there is limited,
as she must return to Zambesi.
After the timeline is changed,
Mari and Kuasa decide to share the Anansi Totem,
growing up in solidarity, instead of as enemies.
However, no matter where they go or what they
do, their allegiance to their village and their
willingness to do whatever it takes to save it
makes this a permanent area of vulnerability.
A shapeshifter, Charlie has a serious hatred
of authority and a general distrust of others.
Eons ago, she was Clotho, one of the three
mythological Fates. She decided to break the
loom that gave her and her sisters control
over mortal lives, however. She's been on
the run from her sisters Atropos and Lachesis
ever since. Even when she's with the Legends,
she is guarded about her past, and doesn't trust
them enough to tell them her secrets. Coming clean
might have prevented a lot of grief, as the
other two Fates eventually catch up with her.
In many ways, Nora Darhk is the most unlikely
Legend of all. The daughter of their enemy Damien
Darhk, her parents died when they tried to destroy
most of the world in one of Damien's schemes.
She is later connected to a cult and enslaved
by the demon Mallus in an effort to resurrect
him. She is severely scarred and
traumatized by the experience.
Despite all of this, Ray Palmer shows
her nothing but kindness, seeing only
the good in her. When Damien sees this, he
sacrifices his own life to save his daughter's.
Nora's time as a Fairy Godmother allows her to
work through some of her childhood trauma, but
it takes embarking on a new life with Ray as his
wife and leaving the Legends behind to truly heal.
Nate Heywood is a big, nerdy kid who gets
to use his knowledge of historical data to
have the biggest adventure of his life. He loves
his friends and will do anything for them. Nate,
Ray, and Behrad form a sort of sub-fraternity
in the Legends, goofing around together and
exchanging many high fives. But this endearing
quality of Nate's is also his weakness,
as he can be emotionally manipulated in the same
way a kid can. Not having a father who showed
him love means that he searches constantly
for outside approval, and often makes poor
decisions based on his feelings. Fortunately for
him, he has the Legends to keep him grounded.
Mona Wu is sweet and naive. But that
niceness conceals a nasty, violent temper.
She doesn't just get angry — she has tantrums.
This impulsiveness is what gets her mixed up
with the Legends in the first place. When
she is scratched by a werewolf-like creature
called the Kaupe, she is transformed into
one herself. Suddenly, when she gets mad,
she turns into her "Wolfie" form and is perfectly
happy to attack both friends and foe alike. Anyone
who triggers a tantrum is fair game, which makes
her more than a little unstable as a teammate.
When the Legends change the timeline and Zari
Tomaz is replaced by her brother Behrad, it means
that she suddenly disappeared into the Air Totem.
This is where the spirits of its former wielders
live — but Zari the adventurer never existed in
the new timeline. Instead, there is Zari Tarazi,
the highly-pampered social media influencer.
This Zari accidentally discovers her brother is a
superhero and starts hanging out with the team. As
she learns about her other self and realizes that
flashes of her abilities have started to bubble
up in her, she stays with the Legends. However,
she's still self-important, arrogant, and high
maintenance. She's just aggressive enough to get
away with it, but there are definitely
times she's tolerated more than loved.
When the timeline is altered, Zari's brother
Behrad Tarazi becomes the Air Totem-bearing member
of the Legends. On a team of slackers and
degenerates, Behrad still stands out as
the most mellow member of the Legends, with a
supremely laid back personality. He's a little
too relaxed at times, in fact, as he doesn't
always take things as seriously as he needs to.
For him, these missions aren't life-and-death,
but a spirited adventure he's glad to be taking.
This attitude can be nice to be around,
but it also makes him hard to depend on.
Leo Snart is a Freedom Fighter
from the Nazi-ruled Earth-X.
After meeting the Legends, he decides to
briefly join the team and hang out on Earth-1.
Quite unlike his Earth-1 counterpart, this Leo
is meticulous and hates the Legends' sloppy ways.
He particularly chastises Rory for using his
flamethrower indiscriminately. He doesn't stay
with the Legends for very long, and though the
reasons why aren't related to his particular ways,
he likely knows he's too fastidious to be
a long-term fit with this group of misfits.
James Olsen is tired of feeling left out — that's
why he becomes the armored Guardian. However,
after James is shot, Lena Luthor injects him with
the Kryptonian Harun-El serum. James gains actual
Kryptonian super-powers and loses control of them
when he struggles with PTSD-related panic attacks.
With professional help, he is able to
get through this, and in time, his system
is purged of the serum. But the trauma of
the experiences, often triggered by hearing
gunshots or simply seeing Lex Luthor, is
something he will always have to manage.
Nia takes up the mantle of
Dreamer after her mother,
the previous Dreamer, dies. Nia is an intense
perfectionist and her own worst critic.
This is exacerbated by her imperfect control
of her precognitive and dream-related powers,
which leads her to misunderstand that her mother
is going to die. Nia has a lot to live up to as
Dreamer, and she knows it, putting too much
pressure on herself as a result. However,
she slowly overcomes this as she becomes
more confident and learns to ask for help.
Mon-El and Kara are an unlikely
couple, but their bond is real.
Tragically, they are separated when he is forced
to go to the 31st century for his own safety.
There, he founds the Legion and marries fellow
member Imra. When they go back in time and he
finds himself face-to-face with Kara, he tries
to put her off, but it's not long before he
realizes that he's still in love with her. This
starts to affect his judgment, his marriage,
and even the foundations of his heroism. He bases
too much of himself on her and eventually returns
to the 31st century because he knows he has to,
putting the greater good above his own desires.
J'onn J'onnz hates fire, which scares him so
badly, it affects his shapeshifting. However,
what haunts him even more deeply is survivor's
guilt. He believes himself to be the last of
the Green Martians, who were wiped out in a
genocide perpetrated by the White Martians.
Even though he's since learned that his younger
brother and father are alive, J'onn never recovers
from the death of his wife and children. He
still feels guilty for living while they cannot.
Enemies often exploit this chink in his
armor through the use of psychic attacks.
Querl Dox is a tactical genius, an efficient
fighter, and an all-around powerhouse of digital
might. However, he's wary of his ancestry, being
born into the Brainiac clan, descendants of one of
Superman's most relentless enemies. Kind-hearted
"Brainy" worries that evil lurks within him as
well, and not without cause: He is cut off
from his emotions when his mind is rebooted,
only regaining them and his sense of empathy when
he sees the love of his life, Nia Nal, in danger.
Anissa Pierce is a brilliant young medical
student, part-time teacher, and community
activist. Her strong ideals are backed up by her
courage and steely resolve. When she realizes that
she has superpowers, she keeps them hidden
so she can figure out what she is capable of
in private. Still, she is reckless in attacking
the various gangs that plague Freeland. When her
father finally gives her his blessing in exchange
for working as a team, she makes fewer mistakes in
the field. Of course, she then concocts an
entirely new persona, Blackbird, that robs
from gangs and gives money to the church and needy
people. She just can't help being a loose cannon.
Jennifer Pierce never wanted superpowers,
but she gets them anyway. As she's not a
natural fighter like her father and sister, she
tries to minimize their effect upon her life.
Her powers just can't be denied, however: When
she tries to not use them, they build up and
cause her intense pain. Unlike Jefferson, who is
something of a battery, Jen is a generator. This
means that she can do pretty much anything her dad
can, but isn't at risk of running out of juice.
Accepting her powers comes slowly to her, but
fighting for her family makes it possible.
Cisco Ramon is an integral part of Team Flash as
a hacker, leader, and tech guy. But being betrayed
by his mentor, who is actually the Reverse-Flash,
makes Cisco distrustful of everyone.
That even includes his best friend Barry Allen,
as he creates a weapon to stop him, just in case
he turns evil, goes insane, or otherwise loses
control of his powers. This approach means Ramon
is always a little on edge with everyone, even
as he projects an easygoing, friendly demeanor.
After being introduced to the
nasty Killer Frost of Earth-2
and realizing that her ex-lover
is actually the murderous Zoom,
Caitlin Snow slowly starts to feel her
long-dormant second personality emerge.
When her other side takes over, she is every bit
as vicious as her Earth-2 counterpart. However,
the love shown to her by members of Team Flash
allows both Caitlin and Killer Frost to co-exist,
taking turns "driving." Still, this relationship
with her other self has its ups and downs.
When her two sides quarrel or don't
feel they're getting enough time
"driving," Caitlin gets
more than a little unstable.
When Ralph Dibny first receives his
powers, he's a private detective.
He works as a PI because he was disgraced
as a cop, having planted false evidence.
When he becomes a hero and starts taking
Barry Allen's lessons and example to heart,
he legitimately changes his ways
and stops cutting moral corners.
"I don't do that kind of stuff
anymore. Ralph Dibny's gone straight."
"You serious?" I got friends
now. They're good people."
However, Ralph's icky personality endures
— especially when it comes to dealing with
women. His romantic "advice" to others is like
something out of a pick-up artist handbook.
What's more, even as Ralph has gained humility
in many ways, he still sees himself as a font of
wisdom. He's just too in love with his own
patter to take a hard look in the mirror.
Wally West is one of the most unsettled heroes in
the Arrowverse. Having grown up in dysfunctional
circumstances, he struggles with tension and
jealousy. When he gains his own super speed,
he is reckless and a bit of a glory hog.
He is so overjoyed to have superpowers,
in fact, that he starts to use
them for the wrong reasons.
Though he eventually comes to terms with his
anger and jealousy, he leaves Central City — he
just never manages to feel like he fits in. He
goes off to find himself in a Buddhist monastery,
and is later convinced to join the Legends. Wally
makes some friends, but eventually quits that too.
Kid Flash could be an all-star superhero,
but his lack of direction holds him back.
In many ways, Kate Kane is a better superhero
than her cousin, Bruce Wayne: She's more flexible
in her thinking and more willing to ask for
help. Furthermore, she is a steadying force
when she becomes the paragon of courage during the
Crisis. However, the return of her seemingly dead
twin sister Beth as the psychotic criminal Alice
repeatedly leads Batwoman to make major mistakes.
Kate captures and lets her go on more than
one occasion, despite her homicidal ways.
The survivor's guilt Kate feels over the fact
that she stopped looking for Beth years earlier
is simply more than she can bear. As a result,
more than one person she cares about is murdered,
and Kate has to deal with knowing that they'd
likely be alive if she'd had more resolve.
As you likely know, Superman's biggest physical
weakness is green kryptonite, which is lethal
in large enough doses. Furthermore, red kryptonite
turns him evil and silver kryptonite makes him
hallucinate. He's also vulnerable to magic
and mind control. However, his real weakness
is the love of his life, Lois Lane, and his
adoptive parents, Martha and Jonathan Kent.
He's terrified of enemies learning about them,
and now he's frightened that something will
happen to his new baby. This doesn't
stop him from doing the right thing,
but enemies who know anything about him know to
strike at him through his family. Lex Luthor,
his arch-enemy, knows this most keenly of all.
When Courtney Whitmore discovers the cosmic
staff among her stepfather's belongings,
everything changes. The staff allows
her to bond with it to become Stargirl,
and she sets about forming a new Justice
Society. Despite her stepfather's warnings,
over-eager Courtney makes a lot of mistakes
with her recklessness, even getting people
killed. She thinks that having powers and
her own team will somehow solve everything,
without considering that the original
Justice Society also had their own powers,
and were still murdered by their enemies.
While she eventually calms down a little
with regard to leading the new JSA, she still
tends to act without thinking things through.
Jefferson Pierce's paternalistic attitude
doesn't just affect his family, but the
people he works with as well. In thinking
he knows how to protect everyone best,
he often makes unilateral decisions that don't
respect the agency of his super-powered daughters,
his highly capable wife, his students, and even
his allies in the Freeland Police Department.
It takes him a long time to figure out that
people are going to do what they want to do,
and that he has to cooperate. The irony of this
is that as a school principal, his whole job is
trying to find ways to empower young people.
As a superhero, he doesn't do that enough.
Sara Lance starts off as a party girl who has
an affair with her sister Laurel's boyfriend,
Oliver Queen. After their ill-fated yacht trip,
she does what she has to do to survive: She
helps torture people aboard the Amazo, joins the
League of Assassins, and becomes a trained killer.
Eventually, she breaks away to become a vigilante.
Though she dies, she is resurrected — but her
reanimated body lacks a soul, which leads to
her becoming a killing machine. Even when her
soul is reunited with her body, she is haunted
by the rage inside of her that she often can't
control. Nora Darhk is eventually able to help
her with this, but it doesn't erase her past.
Of all the heroes in the Arrowverse, Kara Danvers
is surely the nicest. She's a kind, compassionate,
and loving person who works well on her own and
as part of a larger team. She's also willing
to see the good in nearly everyone, which can
be a liability. You can't blame her too much:
How would you handle birth parents who
invent horrifying technology designed
to murder and/or enslave people? Her adoptive
father, Jeremiah Danvers, isn't much better:
He's a double agent who uses Kara's trusting
nature to hide his betrayal. Her naivete has faded
after these experiences, and she's become more
battle-hardened and confident. But she's still
the paragon of hope, and while that's very much a
strength, this optimism is often used against her.
Barry Allen's inherent decency is his greatest
strength: It makes him a wonderful friend,
a great team member, and a stalwart hero. However,
once Barry makes up his mind about something,
it's impossible to get him to change course.
He'd rather learn by catastrophic example
than accept the wisdom of others. That's
especially true if the stakes are personal.
The trauma of seeing his parents killed unhinges
him to the point where he alters the timeline,
inadvertently changing the lives of everyone
he loves ... and not always for the better.
He frantically tries to fix this mess,
but things never quite return to normal.
It takes Earth-2's Flash, Jay Garrick, to
teach him that he simply has to let it go.
Barry mostly avoids mucking with the timeline
following this crisis, but not entirely.
Oliver Queen thinks that he knows best for
everyone, and rarely deviates from acting
on this belief. He is enormously distrustful,
conceals secrets, and openly lies in the name
of protecting his loved ones. This alienates
much of Team Arrow, and nearly destroys his
relationship with Felicity Smoak. Admittedly, his
unilateral decision-making does save the universe:
Oliver sacrifices himself in order
to create the new Earth-Prime and
resurrects billions of lives. It's almost
as though he knows his form of leadership
is no longer viable in this new world. He
can't change his domineering ways ... and
so he makes one final, sweeping choice
that takes him out of the equation.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite Arrowverse characters
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.